what a waste of energy
sure
of course you are quite terrifying
please
put down the knife
hey
let someone else tend to the priest we
should be searching the surroundings
thank you
it's not a serious injury
i think it's already something at least
too late for these people to cost that
priest a fortune
i already gave some the potion
the treasure is important but making it
out alive is what truly matters
make good use of that potion
[Music]
um
um
we never know what's gonna happen so
it's best to prepare for the worst
we never know what's gonna happen so
it's best to prepare for the worst
this way
hey
everyone gather up and you're going to
break through the barrier and advance
[Applause]
it is believed the ruins of trua are
protected by the gods
between traps and crumbling ceilings we
should be careful
whoa
these giant statues were built in the
image of the gods
regulus himself created the ark
the ever burning light of creation
the ark contains great power
the power to create
and the power to destroy
just
like a god
if only we could figure out its location
oh
you're gonna flap your gums all day
priest
he's right we should be quiet
look
we made it
[Applause]
this place
it doesn't seem
normal
seems like we're on the right track
follow me
and watch your step
the early bird that gets you stay put
it's the trolls again we have to break
through their lines
prepare for battle
more twirls incoming
i can't believe you destroyed the bridge
what about the others trapped on the
other side
don't whine at me
did you have a death wish it had to be
done
i'm glad you're okay
i was just making a rational decision to
save everyone
hmm
this seems like the entrance to the city
but it's blocked
when in doubt
blow it up
run as fast as you can once you set it
up
that thing goes off fast i hope nothing
goes wrong
this is an ancient magic
damn that stone ain't gonna budge
is there another way
[Music]
the path
it's open
what is this
[Music]